e aí
e as ruas eu falo
e nas ruas eu escancaro tudo que me
angustia
é através do silêncio quebra as
barreiras sociais me liberto das amarras
de condicionamentos mecanizados quando
sinal fecha quem entra em cena não sou
eu matéria mas o eu luz que ilumina o
motorista cansado ilumina o pedestre mal
humorado que ilumina apatia social
o que me cura
a cura gestor ções das mentes e unifica
tudo que há em um imenso instante de
amor
e aí
[Música]
oi eu me chamo paloma betina trabalho
com arte de rua já vai fazer 7 anos eu
encontrei esse aparelho aqui que se
chama malabarismo de contato através de
um canal chamado malabarize-se no
youtube como não haviam professores na
época comecei a tentar fazer em casa até
que me apaixonei por essa arte e fiquei
um ano treinando em torno de sete horas
por dia
e depois de um ano eu resolvi para rua
me apresentar foi tudo muito bonito
porque eu comecei a enxergar a vida de
uma forma diferente os artistas eu já
enxergava de uma forma diferente porque
desde criança o meu olho sempre brilhou
vendo a arte de rua vendo quanto que que
é bonito um dia qualquer encontrar
artistas sem que a gente estelle ou às
vezes a gente está triste encontra o
artista na rua eu sempre fiquei muito
feliz então queria estar naquele lugar
só que a minha família não gostou muito
que eu fui para rua os meus colegas de
trabalho não gostaram também porque
começaram a dizer que eu tinha decaído
na vida eu já trabalhava com teatro há
quatro anos antes mas resolvi ir para
rua muitas vezes eles me encontrava diz
o que que tu tá fazendo aí e eu falava
eu tô trabalhando esse é o meu trabalho
agora é esse é o meu trabalho
é mas mesmo passando por todas essas
coisas que me diziam não eu me
reafirmava todos os dias porque todos os
dias tinha uma história diferente tinha
um abraço tinha um olhar tinha um
carinho muito além das moedas porque a
moeda da rua ela não alimenta só o meu
corpo alimenta minha alma porque ninguém
na rua tem obrigação de me dar dinheiro
e quem me dá dinheiro é porque tá dando
decoração aberta então toda vez que eu
pego uma moeda e vou lá na padaria tomar
um café eu tô alimentando a minha alma
toda vez que eu pago uma passagem que eu
compro um rancho eu sei que eu estou
alimentando a minha alma porque as
pessoas não estão doando só o dinheiro
só o material mas o momento de carinho
um momento de vida arte de rua é vida
desperta vida e nós as pessoas entram
nos seus carros e vão até a casa
é a entra no seus carros vão até o
trabalho e volto até casa como robôs e
de repente tem um artista que te
desperta
e muitas vezes as pessoas não vão me dar
um sorriso mas alguma coisa vai
incomodar naquela pessoa e eu me sinto
feliz quando incomoda também porque
alguma coisa tá despertando o que que
essa pessoa tá fazendo ali por que que
essa menina tá na rua porque que ela não
tá na tv é uma pessoa tão bonita você me
pergunta por que tá tão bonita eu fiquei
que você não vai para a televisão porque
eu amo estar na rua é o que me torna
humano é o que faz eu me sentir ser
humano além de estar nos holofotes na
frente das câmeras é o que faz me sentir
humano é o que faz eu me conectar com as
pessoas quando um vidro baixo e põe uma
moeda no meu chapéu é um momento de
alegria que eu tenho
e eu tava trabalhando de manhã
o e passou o senhor todo sujo assim
juntando lixo e falou bom dia eu parei a
minha apresentação abre espaço para ele
falei bom dia voltei a fazer a minha
apresentação daqui a pouco ele volta e
com sorriso no rosto e fala assim essas
são as minhas últimas moedas eu enche
meus olhos de lágrima e agradeci e não
consegui nem apresentar eu sentei na
calçada e chorei porque às vezes as
últimas são dez centavos mas é tudo que
a pessoa tem na vida para comer então eu
toquei o coração daquela pessoa alimenta
a alma dela também
a e agora eu também faço poesias no trem
recita poesias e eu vou finalizar sua
apresentação com a poesia que eu faço
nos trens peço licença para chegar nesse
instante passageiros dessa vida sou eu
artista e poeta na arte mikuru e cura
feridas com a arte de rua eu ganho pão a
rua é uma escolha e não falta de opção
é do que adianta ganhar muito dinheiro e
deixar a ganância destruir as coisas que
vem do coração enquanto os poderosos
constroem bombas a arte traz a esperança
se o mundo ficar melhor vai ser com
ajuda da arte e não por quem escraviza o
povo e não cuida de educação das
crianças olhem bem amigos prestem muita
atenção somos tratados feito máquinas
programadas para destruição compramos
carros luxuosos que destroem a natureza
sou é rico quem percebe que a
simplicidade de um carinho é a nossa
maior riqueza
oi e o clichê é este quando nós mudamos
o mundo também muda se utilizarmos
melhor a internet dá tempo de ajudar
quem precisa de ajuda agradeço pela
oportunidade de poder me expressar não
guardem os seus poemas na gaveta o povo
precisa se comunicar contribuir com a
arte de rua é garantido em cada esquina
tem a mais segurança mas vale um artista
nos fazendo sorrir do que um corrupto
desviando o dinheiro da merenda das
crianças pensem o quanto vocês gostariam
de receber se estivessem no meu lugar
quem contribui com o artista permite que
outras lentes possam ampliar toda ajuda
é grande quando vem do coração até uma
próxima nos vemos na rua ou em alguma
estação gratidão
e aí